what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time on a monday
while wall street is trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right i'm here with the
beautiful intelligent pelina pompliano
she's looking like she's in miami why do
you have
uh palm trees on your shirt um because i
was feeling um
uh festive you know what that shirt
looks like especially because you have
it open like that
it looks like you're a uh uh in uh wolf
of wall street
no it looks like you're a cocaine addict
from the 1970s walking on miami beach
being like
a man amen all right what's going on
with the
oh wait before we forget hold on big
news duh we have a sponsor it's called
block five
i'm an investor and a user i love it
they have three products you can buy and
sell crypto you can deposit crypto and
get a us dollar alone
or my favorite product is you can
deposit crypto and you can earn up to
eight point six percent apy
it's like having a nice little that's
how you deposit it yeah it's like a
little three-point shot
nothing but net and if you can earn up
to eight point six percent apy
no brainer block fight.com slash lunch
money go in the description click on the
link
help us be cool and make them think that
we
are very valuable to them all right
what's going on with cobit relief
you can't just tell people to tell
people that you're cool
um i just did make us cool guys make us
cool
i was gonna go so white house economic
advisor larry kudlow
says that coronavirus relief will
include
twelve hundred dollar checks and
extension
and extension of eviction moratorium
wait a second so is this part of a new
stimulus package
so uh yes but before we get into that
detail real quick
i just want to make one point larry
kudlow doesn't get to make this decision
so larry kudlow has no clue what's going
to happen
that's what he says i know but larry
kudlow's frankly
been wrong over and over and over again
during the uh entire situation the
entire pandemic where are some palm
trees no he actually wears ridiculous
ties sometimes on top see right there
look at that ridiculous tie he has on
he wears uh sometimes he has the stripes
going down or was that pin stripes i
guess
and then he wears ties that go diagonal
it's like you got so many things going
on it just kind of looks what do you
know about clashing
stripes i don't know anything but i know
that that's wrong and if i know that
it's wrong then it's definitely come on
come on
all right so covid relief uh basically
there was 2.4 trillion dollars of
stimulus
already approved the big was the two
trillion dollar stimulus package back in
march that was kind of an unprecedented
thing remember both parties on the
political spectrum have to agree
to the package so they negotiate right
now
there's a bunch of programs that are
expiring so the unemployment benefits
are going to expire at the end of this
month literally in like a day or two
uh then you get at the end of september
uh the pvp
loan period is going to be gone and
people can start firing the employees
there was no more stimulus checks going
directly to americans all these problems
so the democrats put forward a couple of
weeks ago a three trillion dollar
stimulus package a second package worth
three trillion dollars
the republicans said that's way too much
money we don't want to spend that much
money we're very fiscally responsible
and so we only want to spend a trillion
dollars either way there's gonna be a
trillion to three trillion dollars
somewhere in there
that they're going to put together in a
package how they give the money to
people
who knows they'll find all kinds of
exhaustion but i'm confused so the 600
weekly supplement that people were
getting
will expire at the end of july yep and
then will it be
immediately after that they get
something or
will they have to wait so basically
think of it as like there's a shot clock
right now
and time is ticking down and if they
don't reach a deal
before uh july 31st basically you're not
going to get the check
so you're going to lose that 600
supplemental piece of it so let's say
that
you would make i'll make up easy numbers
500 a week from your state unemployment
uh
traditional you know mechanism and then
there was an extra six hundred dollars
so you're making eleven hundred dollars
for the last number of weeks
right through unemployment next week if
they don't reach a deal you're only
gonna make five hundred dollars
so you're gonna lose more than fifty
percent of the money you're losing on it
or that you're making unemployment now
the republicans are saying we don't want
to extend it at 600
they do want to add more uh kind of
supplement to unemployment but they want
to do something in like the three to
four hundred dollar range not six
hundred dollars
i see so basically what ends up
happening is they're going to print a
ton more money
and bitcoin and gold are going to
continue but like like you and i talk
about
it's very hard once you've gotten people
used to something to suddenly take it
away
even if it was supposed to be temporary
it ended in an election year what
politicians going to go on state
uh go on television right now and be
like you know what we know that we've
been giving you 1100
a week we're going to take it away from
you there's nobody
you can't say that right like it's
political suicide
and on top of that people like the larry
kudlow's of the world
what they are doing is they are
systematically devaluing the currency
and that is driving asset prices through
the roof and they are
literally going to try to buy votes this
way this is this is what happens
they're going to devalue the currency
asset prices will explode
and what happens is in an election year
everyone's looking around the room
saying oh i'm getting rich
i'm literally getting rich because all
the asset prices are going up the bottom
50
who usually have the lowest turnout in
terms of voting
they're gonna have their savings and um
all of their kind of paycheck
absolutely crushed because they're
getting paid uh in cash and their
paycheck to paycheck but the rich people
who go out and they vote they're getting
rich
and so it's a way for an incumbent
regardless of what side of the aisle
they're on
to basically enrich everybody right
before the election they go and they
re-vote and then they would a second
term yikes okay sad news bears
get out of cash and get into inflation
hedge assets
guys the other day he called me a bad
mood bear
i remember that no bad mood bear i think
she's making it no
come on let's go are you here being a
bad mood bear
sap plans to spin out qualtrics at
software unit
that it acquired for eight billion
dollars in 2018
for an ipo do you think this is a good
idea yes
why uh i think can do well on its own
okay that was the tony montagna analysis
of the ipo market i guess
no i look at at the end of the day sap
basically doesn't want this on their
balance sheet anymore
and so you can sell it you can um kind
of spin it out in a private company
uh and still own it or you can bring it
into the public markets it actually
makes a bunch of sense can you tell me
what
tricks even does uh if i remember
correctly they basically are doing um
all sorts of the uh analytics and um
they kind of do like xm uh experience
management
it's basically like when you come into a
product right yes it's like survey
yeah but but it's experience management
in the sense of uh when you come into a
product
and you go through it they most
companies can't get feedback so they
just look at data
right and all they're saying is like oh
did you click on that button did you do
this do you do that
now what they'll do is they'll actually
give you a survey and say hey did you
like the product
what could be improved what about ground
breaking
it's a multi-billion dollar company so
it's pretty groundbreaking i could have
made that company let's be real
okay you're two bidding in in miami with
tony montana
all right what's going on with regis
philbin
oh no he died okay so we just did regis
passed away over the weekend at age 88
he was mostly maybe a long time most
well-known for
who wants to be a millionaire which used
to be my favorite show when we moved to
the us
and i loved it so much that i literally
begged my parents to buy me the board
game and then i would terrorize them
into playing with me
every night but you know what when you
don't really know english
it makes you look up in the dictionary
like what some of the words mean and you
know a lot of trivia
oh sorry your nerd talk put me to sleep
there for a second
you're playing board games when i was
like nine yes
oh i didn't play no board games okay nah
i
i was uh what do you have to say about
something
r.i.p i liked him a lot yeah he's like
oh he's like a nice old man
it's great and and the part that i like
is that he always seemed to be happy
and make other people feel happy yeah
60-year career doing it so
he actually had a late start started 28
years old in his television personality
career
do you want to tell them about your
favorite uh who wants to be a
millionaire video
oh yeah it was going viral again on the
internet this weekend but uh basically
the very first guy to ever win the
million dollars very first yeah very
first one ever
on the show uh he gets to the final uh
question regis asks him the question
and he goes uh i would like to uh i'd
like to phone a friend i'd like to call
my father
and uh so regis you know at t please
call uh
you know the gentleman's father and uh
so dad answers the phone and he goes uh
sir
you know this is uh regis philbin with
uh who wants to be a millionaire
your son is at the final thing he's
already won half a million dollars
he's not going for the million dollar
question here's the question uh let us
know
go ahead and the guy literally says hey
dad i don't need any help i just wanted
to call you and let you know i'm about
to win a million dollars that's amazing
and then he answers the question and
gets it right
and it's it's probably one of the most
uh
um arrogant things on television
but the funniest part is that the dude
knew the
answer the question and just sat there
because she had a lifeline left to me
i'd call my dad real quick do you think
he planned to do that
if he like previous to the show or do
you think
in the moment he was like i'mma do this
no he
he probably thought of it in the moment
oh you think so yeah
okay tony montagna all right what's
going on with elon musk
what's going on with you what is elon
doing today okay so elon today
is having a year man elon is having a
year he's having baby
baby x which is the baby is now known
just as baby x because
ain't nobody pronouncing his name um but
uh the new york times did this kind of
bizarre interview with
elon which goes all over the map i'm not
exactly sure what's going on here i
didn't think it was bizarre
i thought it was weird but um so at the
end
the reporter does a uh would you rather
game
with elon and she says would you
is this true or false you'd rather be a
meme lord than a billionaire
and he says probably true you know you
need resources in order to make life
multi-planetary that's the reason i'm
accumulating resources
but i don't otherwise care about
resources
a dude who is the ninth richest person
in the world would rather be
would rather be a meme lord than a
billionaire shout out to all the meme
lords out there
[Music]
like what an absolute savage
and he told the new york times that and
then he said he's not worried so they
asked him about the twitter hack and
he's he's like
what am i worried about i'm not worried
about somebody leaking my dms
he said i mean we can probably cherry
pick some section of my dms that sound
bad out of context but overall my dm's
mostly consist of swapping memes
the meme is the message welcome to
meanville
all right are you ready for this meme
lord elon musk that's what i want the
next new york times headline to be
meme lord elon musk are you ready for
this what's up with the coin shortage
the u.s mint is pleading with americans
to start spending their coins after the
coronavirus pandemic sparked
a national coin shortage this is dumb
why are they doing this who cares about
coins just get rid of the coins
like this is so stupid well they're
running low
yeah they're pleading because people
aren't spending their coins
they're holding on to their coins no
people are little don't have coins who
do you know that has coins
a lot of people like what is this
dinosaur land
i think i actually think i have coins in
a bag over there yeah literally you have
coins in a bag you must really be using
those
like exactly nobody's using that because
it's stupid why would you carry around
coins it's 20 20.
just digitize it already stop wasting
time
money energy right all this nonsense
i believe it's still true that it cost
the u.s mint two cents
to make a penny really i'm pretty sure
that that's true
no just google it real quick i believe
that it cost the u.s mint two cents to
make a penny which means that the united
states government spends
twice as much it costs 1.79
cents yep that was in 2010. so that
means that it might have gone up earlier
and in 2011 no go back in 2011 it cost
2.41 cents
and in uh 2016 it got it dropped all the
way to 1.50 or
1.5 cents so it costs more money for the
u.s mint to make a penny than the
penny's actually worth
so newsflash why would you continue to
make something that is not profitable
it's like a startup with bad unit
economics
that's what the government does they're
inefficient just get rid of it let me
tell the people so in 2019 it costs two
cents to make a penny in seven cents to
make a nickel
that ain't good these are the people
that you're that they're taking your cat
your tax revenue
and this is what they're doing with it
they're spending two cents to make one
cent they're spending seven cents to
make five
cents no absolute insanity
all right what's going on i'm done get
rid of all the coins give them to the
meme lord
elon musk so the pentagon
is deciding to reveal findings
on unexplained materials and crashes aka
ufos
and an astrophysicist who consulted on
the ufo program
confirms the government possesses
materials from off-world
vehicles not made on this earth yo bob
lazar
shout out dog is that bomb bob lazar was
the one who broke this whole thing open
like 30 years ago okay but yeah this is
fascinating
bob lazar for those that don't know uh
there's documentary on netflix i
actually haven't seen the documentary
but i've heard
a number of interviews that bob lazar's
done
bob lazar worked at area 51 um
in something called i think it was st4
or something
it basically was a a portion and what he
basically claims is that the united
states has
possession of multiple flying saucers
that they can operate that they
literally
people would get in and they would fly
them around and try to figure it out
but they could not explain the physics
and the propulsion and all of the
science behind how they are
how it goes without any um exhaust
yeah so basically everyone's always like
oh are aliens real or not right it's one
of my favorite questions to ask everyone
wants to talk about ufos i think i saw
one i don't know what it was all this
stuff
the part that becomes very realistic and
actually
is if you're intellectually curious
where people kind of lean in and say
wait a second
like that's actually what i want to talk
about is the science
if we have possession of things
that move in a way that we as humans
cannot explain
obviously they move some way that we
don't understand so it's not like it's a
made-up
maybe it's north korea well so that's
one of the arguments is it could just be
another country but based on all of the
science that we understand
it does not appear to be anything that
can be replicated here on earth
and that's what they're trying to figure
out okay uh can i ask
why they decided to start revealing and
making
findings public now well that's
one big question is why now but
over a long period of time there have
been
multiple leaks like the ufo videos that
were released earlier this year
uh by the government and confirmed those
got leaked on reddit in like 2015.
right tony montana don't he don't go to
sleep
no sleeping man all right so basically
what ends up happening
is uh the other thing is bob lazar i
think it was in the late 80s or early
90s if i remember
i may have the timeline wrong but he
basically came out was like hey i saw
them like i worked on them
he literally is a propulsion expert who
worked at area 15
and was like yo dude there's literally
some sort of alien crap that we don't
understand that we were trying to figure
out
i will say i'm not a big conspiracy
theorist person but
that bob lazar guy just something about
him just seems
very believable and trustworthy i don't
think he would be lying if he
like i i don't think he's doing it for
the fame he never
changed his story in like 20 or 30 yeah
and he's able to explain it the same
everyday
it's just yeah it's pretty crazy so
look at the end of the day there's a
difference between ufos
and aliens obviously ufos are something
that we can't identify
there was a period in time where humans
couldn't explain gravity
we had no clue why are we stuck to the
ground when i tried to jump why don't i
just float away
right no one understood it eventually we
understood the science behind gravity
and now gravity is a well understood
thing
everyone gets it whatever eventually we
will understand
how these things scientifically work
but the whole kind of interest or
intrigue
is is it something that we can replicate
here
on earth or is it something that was
created somewhere else
and therefore we are not um kind of
advanced enough to actually get it but i
actually
i don't think like aliens i don't think
would have
the same type of technology and
materials and stuff as us like i just
don't buy that
well materials just come out of the
earth i know by the way guys
let me take a break to tell you what
happened to me last night 11 p.m
he goes oh do you mind if i go live
right now i was like
oh we were gonna play chess chess went
out the window
he went live with peter schiff for like
an hour and a half
oh my god and then literally i tuned
back into the conversation and all i
hear is
peter you can't sit here and tell me
that an
alien would rather get gold or
you know over bitcoin because the gold's
too heavy to bring back to their planet
and i was like
what am i listening to yeah peter schiff
was trying to explain
to me uh that if people found gold in
space they would bring it back to earth
and i told him he was crazy oh you said
something about aliens
yeah but then he said that the aliens uh
wouldn't know what to do with bitcoin
but they would know what to do with gold
and i was like all right and then the
periodic
table he doesn't like he doesn't like
that one because he always asks me what
is the difference between bitcoin and
all the other cryptocurrencies and then
i just hit him with what's the
difference between gold and any of the
other elements on the periodic table
and then he's just like
yeah what's your joke you got a joke i
don't have a joke you don't have one
no oh i try to find an alien joke
no not orange knock knock no knock knock
i refuse to open the door
knock knock what no knock knock who's
there orange
aren't you annoying orange orange
what orange you glad that i make fun of
you all day and you get a laugh
just wait till you see what my outfit
for tomorrow is you don't even know
you don't even guys choose make sure you
tune in tomorrow
just for the beginning if you must but
like he's gonna lose
also just so everyone at home is keeping
track of the uh the chess match there
was a crime scene
in our apartment this past weekend i
went on a 3-0 run
on one one time i didn't even move eight
that's
eight pieces eight of my chest pieces i
didn't move
and i took every single one of hers off
what do you call a boomerang that won't
come back
a flyaway no what a stick
because you throw it and then it just
doesn't come back
that's how funny that was all right guys
that's it for lunch monday today while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
aliens meme lords covid where else
you're gonna get this
hard packing content please subscribe to
the channel we're on our march to a
hundred thousand we're gonna hit it soon
let's go
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends